okay fam there is a new player in the
fire POI Market or at least an old
player coming back for another round at
the table Drex here from Drex Factor POI
sharing with you the love of poi
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm reviewing
the new set of fire POI from fire Mecca
yes that fire Mecca that have just
entered the market but before we dive in
I just want to give a quick shout out to
the Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys juggling calling pyro Terra light
toys spin balls and Ultra POI for
helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these amazing businesses and
what they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links that I've got down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to non-business friends of the
channel Johnny Howard Lane machinsky and
Becca becklinen thank you all so very
much for your support from my work and
my mission so to start with I think some
context will probably be necessary back
in the late 2000s when I first got into
fire spinning and flow Arts the primary
seller of equipment was home of poi and
once you placed an order you'd be
waiting at least two weeks in order to
get it and then Miracle of Miracles a
friend turned me on to an American
manufacturer that had a lot of the same
stuff and from whom shipping took
dramatically less time this company was
called flama Eterna at the time but they
quickly made the correct choice to
change it to something easier to
remember how to spell and they have been
fire Mecca ever since fire Mecca first
made a name for themselves by bringing a
really specific type of fire POI head to
Market they called it the moon Blaze and
it was all the rage for several years
early in the 2010s several other
companies use the same basic design but
with different names but to the best of
my knowledge fire Mecca was the first to
create this Barrel design using a
lanyard dot of half inch wide Kevlar
ribbon then by the mid-2010s they'd kind
of Fallen Into Obscurity but now the
company is Under New Management and
they're back with a brand new take on
fire POI that have at least one feature
that I am super excited about fire Mecca
still has their classic POI sets you
know the ones with the moon Blaze heads
and chain tethers simply because that's
still what a lot of people look for but
now they also have an entry into the
tech nor a fire POI Market with their
elite fire POI available with or without
Ultra knob LED handles from Ultra POI
okay so seriously there are so many
companies out there that make sets of
fire poi
what makes these any different well the
answer has to do with something that
absolutely all of us who spend with
technora Dread you know what I'm talking
about technora degrades over time as
it's exposed to heat and the byproducts
of combustion tethers that have been
used really regularly for a year or more
can sometimes be prone to catastrophic
failures sending the heads careening out
into the world I've witnessed several
technorophails in my day and part of
what makes it so unsettling is that it
seems to happen from out of nowhere
tethers that seem more or less intact
before your burn will come apart once
lit up which don't be mistaken that's
not going to happen the first or the
second time that you use them
but odds are good that it does happen
after several months of heavy use for
this reason I have several performer
friends that just won't use technorite
tethers at all purely because they can't
guarantee when a failure might occur and
that can't happen when they're on a
stage but fire Mecca has a really
ingenious solution to this problem what
sets these tethers apart is that they
actually have a steel safety cable
running through the center of them as a
Fail-Safe so even if your technora does
have a failure the steel cable is in
there as a backup to get you through
your Burns safe and sound brilliant
right so just to be clear the Techno
will break down over time but that steel
cable is in there as a fail safe now
once the technora does fail you are
going to want to replace your tethers
but at least you have some measure of
protection for when that happens so the
next question I imagine many of you will
ask is what impact that has on the feel
of the tethers and honestly the answer
is not very much that steel cable does
stiffen the tether slightly they're just
slightly stiffer than technology tethers
without the reinforcement but honestly I
couldn't find a single trick that I do
where it made any kind of real
difference they're also less stiff than
static tethers so they're a slight
Advantage when it comes to tosses but
not by a whole lot honestly after a few
spins I barely even noticed the
difference between these and my other
techno or tethers now they are currently
only available with the moon Blaze heads
which yes I know monkey fists are what's
in Vogue right now but all that said I
actually found that as I spun them that
the moon Blaze heads were a better fit
for my style of dance-based poi anyhow
the Flames are just slightly smaller
than they would be with monkey fists and
that actually made several moves that I
love accessible earlier in my burn than
they would have been otherwise I'd
actually kind of Forgotten just how good
Moon Blaze heads feel the spin until I
started using these regularly the only
other spot that I really think they
could use some work is that they're
currently using the older Ultra knobs
rather than the ultra knob Pros the pros
are more durable so I'm hoping that they
swap over at some point but for the time
being these totally work for my purposes
these feel great and more than that I
just feel more confident spinning with
them knowing that I have that steel
cable as a fail safe for when the
tethers start to wear out those Moon
Blaze heads are a great fit for my dance
style and you know how I love my LED
handles for doing Gunslingers I'm
actually really excited for these it's
been a while since we had somebody put
something really new Into the Fire POI
market and even if that's not an
addition that's immediately visible it
is one that makes me feel more confident
and comfortable with my own spinning so
great work to Connor and the entire crew
at fire Mecca well done elite fire POI
from fire Mecca are available for
239.99 without LED handles and
289.99 with LED handles over at
firemeka.com and I'm pleased to announce
that they were willing to work with me
to do something that I have literally
been trying to do for nearly a decade
they've become the first fire POI
manufacturer with whom I have a promo
code you can use that code code directs
Factor at checkout to get eight percent
off of your order thanks to fire mecca
for working with me on this one and just
as a quick reminder regardless of whose
fire POI you use out there make sure
that you are using a safety spotter when
you do use them let's keep our community
safe friends
did you get anything out of this video
please make sure to like comment share
and subscribe to help other people find
this video and to help my channel grow
this video would not be possible if not
for the wonderful support of all of
these amazing people right here these
are my flow patrons over on patreon and
they along with the people listed down
in the description helped make this
video and all the videos on my channel
possible thank you one and all for your
very generous support do you like my
videos do you like my flow sessions
Vlogs reviews Combos and more I'm on a
mission to try and bring POI spinning
and flow Arts to The Wider world and
help people connect with their brains
and their bodies so help me do it head
on over to patreon.com
drexfactor POI and sign up you can do
that at the link in the description or
the card that just popped up if you are
watching on YouTube there you can get
access to a whole host of awesome
rewards and you know what even better
you'll be helping me along in my mission
do check that out please and thank you
if you'd like to check out some of my
other reviews of Fire Equipment I will
leave a link to a playlist of those
videos down in the description as well
as up on screen if you are watching this
video on YouTube the YouTube algorithm
also thinks that you'll like this top
video based upon your viewing habits so
maybe give that a look too yeah thanks
so much for watching make sure to get
outside and flow today and I'll see you
with a new video on Wednesday
peace